[Music]
EVO got its start in the arcades of
southern california but has since grown
to the biggest fighting game tournament
in the world over its first 13 years it
went from just a handful of competitors
to over a thousand and it's crowned
champions like Alex via Justin wall and
Daigo Umehara the tournament survived
the dark ages of the mid 2000 and
exploded in 2009 when Street Fighter 4
came out but people couldn't even
imagine just how big it was going to get
[Applause]
Evo began as a way for the American fgc
to come together and settle the score
but eventually it became an
international festival dedicated to
celebrating the fgc preserving arcade
culture and crowning world champions and
after surviving a dark age and
weathering the storm of the mid-2000s
evo bounced back in 2009 thanks in part
to Street Fighter fours arrival oh no
it's all gonna come right down to this
and Justin must admit that was an
excellent match that the crowd is on its
feet after winning in 2009
Street Fighter legend Daigo Umehara
turned his historic legacy into
something more modern more real and in
2010 he did it all over again the Super
Street Fighter 4 tournament at Evo 2010
saw nearly double the entrance but all
the warriors in the world couldn't stop
Daigo who brought down shisa Mike Ross
and beat ricky ortiz twice to take home
his second straight Evo win goggles your
evolution 2010 champion Wow right down
to the last hill road meanwhile the
marvel to show is just about over by the
time Justin won in 2010 it seemed like
it was done as a tournament game Street
Fighter 4 brought Evo back to life but
fans simply couldn't believe that capcom
could do it again that is not until
Marvel vs. Capcom 3
just like with Street Fighter 4 Capcom
did what many thought was impossible and
gave fans a follow-up to a legendary
decade old game it was an era just
before Marvel movies got huge an era
before the fgc would be integrated into
the larger eSports ecosystem it was
basically the only time it could happen
right here can you get it out the level
freak this can Jay Schneider its
evolution 2011 walrus step up the
championship give it up miss can't took
first in 2011 surprising plenty of
people who expected one of the old
Marvel gods to take the tournament but
just entailed behind in third place
Justin Long
he's smiling I know he's gonna take this
one inside he worked really hard and is
in 2012 Justin dropped to a tie for
seven as f champ took the top spot the
next year though Justin got close he was
in the grand finals against Walker and
played an unbelievably close set he's
you know what blocka won but I
definitely get the MVP - just a woman he
added a climb and finally in 2014
Justin reclaimed his drum with an
underdog win against Christian Justin's
win and of course his now iconic pop off
all but ended an era of marvel at Evo
short the game continued to appear at
the tournament for three more years but
things felt like they were slowing down
if only a little Kane Blue River took an
underdog victory in 2015 that caviar has
ever won
what a tournament for it to be Chris G
one in 2016 before a frightening visit
from the spirit of Marvel Randall Chris
G and in 2017
Brian LV the hometown hero won what
looks to be the last official Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 tournament evo will ever see
2017 tsubame vs. Capcom 3 champion well
marvel threes history and Evo with
explosive the franchise elects the event
with more of a whimper Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite was left off the official
roster in 2018 due to weak sales and
even not believing there were enough
players to hold a tournament and while
Marvel will be at the event as a side
tournament the biggest fighting game
tournament in the world looks like it's
leaving one of the games that's built it
behind but in Marvel's glory days at Evo
it created some of the tournament's hype
best moments in 2011 justin wong updated
his legendary 2007 comeback with a new
one in marvel boom got it
Oh baby an eight-year-old Noah solace
shocked the world with his own
incredible marvel play great job in
Street Fighter that year Saudi Arabian
player of a teeth went deeper in Street
Fighter 4 than anyone could have
expected the next year 2012 belonged to
international competitors as
infiltration one Street Fighter 4
[Applause]
attrition has ran and Korea's mad KOF
dueled Mexico's Bala for the King of
Fighters 13 title
[Applause]
15:20 camp your winner is matt baer
laughs 2013 brought controversy but it
also brought back a game that would
change evo forever Evo's organizers
announced the seven tournament games for
2013 in January but also announced a
charity drive to add an eighth game to
the lineup the rules were simpler
whichever community raised the most
money for breast cancer research got
their game at Evo there were over a
dozen games vying for that last spot of
the tournament but the real competition
was between indie darlings skull girls
and melee which hadn't been at Evo since
2007 both games broke five digit
donations but by February melee came out
on top
raising 94618 USA answer research out of
the toil two hundred twenty five
thousand seven hundred and forty four
dollars raised by the FTC at large skull
girls has never been an official Evo
game melee on the other hand would go on
to flourish at evo but not before some
hiccups the day before evo2013 Nintendo
barred the tournament organizers from
not only streaming the melee tournament
but holding it Nintendo has taken it
away from the fans literally saying that
Evo can hold the tournament but you
can't actually host the game this is
freaking ridiculous you can't even they
can't stream now like it's their IP they
can do what they want and they didn't
like they didn't like percent of so many
options to keep it open they were just
hey we want to show you now Nintendo
doubled back on their decision later
that day Evo didn't even do anything
it was the power of the fans who
clamored for their game to be on
fighting games most
most prestigious states we want to be
recognized as a fighting game first of
all and and we also want to be
recognized as in a sport so it was
really really important for us to get it
to Evo so that we can have that
recognition the next year smash was at
Evo and Nintendo sponsor of the
tournament
I wanted to officially wish you luck in
the final stages of the super smash
brothers melee tournament at Evo 2014
smash has gone on to be one of Evo's
biggest games with both melee and super
smash bros for wii u right behind Street
Fighter as the events largest
tournaments year after year mainly went
from 692 players in 2013 to 970 the next
year then 1873 in 2015 and 2,370 3 in
2016
smash 4 which joined Evo and 2015
debuted with 1929 players the next year
it was a 2656
in fact Evo 2015 and 2016 are the four
biggest smash tournaments of all time
smash cemented its place at Evo with
growing attendance numbers
year-over-year but things haven't been
easy tensions between the fighting game
and smash communities have led to plenty
of disagreements between the two scenes
the most notable example smashes
struggle for the Sunday stage I think
male it really really needs to like you
know calm down with that and they really
need to just accept you of what's given
to us like don't like ask for more
you're like we were ready at Evo you
know like you know don't be like you
know
spoiled I think this man is like really
spoiled melee and smash 4 traded their
spots in Sunday stage show back and
forth with the 2017 smash 4 top eight
even being televised on Disney XD the
2017
smash brothers live event Sunday at 6:00
Eastern 3 Pacific on txp meanwhile
certain fighting game fans often
wondered why smash got to have two spots
at Evo while series like Street Fighter
only got one but at this point there's
no getting smash out of Evo and likely
no gettin Evo out of smash this time it
hits and we have our champion mango
first place yet evolution 2014 for super
smash brothers melee signals Evo
spotlight shines bright and like it
brought smashed a new relevance outside
of just the smash community plenty of
games have made a legends at Evo KOF had
yet another incredible Grand Finals in
2013 when a Reynold and Wu battle it was
like so hype and energetic I remember
Raynald putting on the the USA shades
you know yeah the shades with the
American flag on there and after winning
he was waving the American flag and
everything like that that was also like
probably one of the greatest evil top
eight moments as well while CNN Tokyo
Street Fighter 4 grand final set was
somewhat overshadowed by infiltrations
Hakan pick in the loser settings 2014
brought axes now iconic for stock like
silent wolf
an unbelievable run from Belize we
player Galileo God and the biggest win
the ufg Sea had ever taken evolution
2014 to be honest with you I think what
he accomplished is probably one of the
greatest accomplishments of fighting
games you know history to be able to go
through the losers bracket and take out
so many killers and end up winning evil
against a guy like banchan you know who
at the time felt like he was the shoo-in
to win the Evo that year so for me it
was it was a really important moment and
really kind of opened the door for a lot
of for the worldwide scene of street
fighter Evo has changed over the years
though it's not just the games that are
played or the size of the venue it's the
atmosphere well evil got its start as a
way to preserve arcade culture it
eventually became the source of a new
one tournament culture Evo was the first
massive fighting game tournament and
while we have plenty of majors all over
the world now Evo was first and that
means something the community around
fighting ends are amazing like it's so
closing it and very very humble and very
supportive of each other it's a really
great experience almost everyone at Evo
is there to play and even when they're
out there playing casual matches meeting
up with old friends and celebrating
their love of fighting games together
Evo is a mecca for fighting game culture
nearly every fighting game fan in the
world wants to go at least once to know
what it's like to be in that room to
watch that stage to get to play with the
best the worst and everyone else Evo is
a celebration of the fighting game
community but it takes an incredible
group of people to make that celebration
worth it
year after year 2015 might be best known
for the viral what are you standing up
for thought it was over and stood up and
Ogawa gave him no remorse
how does exactly what happens
celebration oh my god but the play in
other tournaments that year was just as
good zero one Evo's first smash 4
tournament without dropping a single
game oh what a play yes he doesn't what
an amazing cup of this myth is feat
Grand Champion here super smash brothers
for Wii U zero from Chile currently
residing in SoCal takes it and in the
Street Fighter 4 grand finals the
unthink
taken down once again the tournament
point for momochi he has to win these
two rounds oh no no no James no James
not like this not like this ma'am oh
she's steak may a broken mid set but he
soldiered through and won the trip
[Music]
[Applause]
perhaps the most notable shift from the
underground Evo's of yesteryear to the
glitz and glamour of the Mandalay Bay
stage broadcast on ESPN is the amount of
developer support the tournament has
seen in recent years capcom first kicked
money into the evo streetfighter prize
pool in 2006 but their contribution has
grown over the years these days their
contributions include more money status
as the biggest tournament on the Capcom
Pro Tour and even new character
announcements Ultra Street Fighter 4 was
even announced at Evo 2013 with a
trailer packed with Evo footage but
Capcom isn't the only company to turn
around and support Evo in the fgc at
large thanks to the tournament's
incredible growth Nintendo went from
blocking smash tournaments in 2013 to
sponsoring Evo every year since Namco
Bandai announced Tekken 7 at Evo 2014
and have been announcing new characters
at Evo ever since
blowing fans away with their geese
Howard announcement in 2017
[Applause]
and Arc System Works has become one of
Evo's biggest supporters announcing you
guilty gear and drag them all fighters
characters along with blaze blue cross
tagging battle at Evo 27 and at launch
cross tag battle was even branded with
the be below go on the shrink-wrap
telling potential buyers that it was an
Evo game but there is some pushback
cross tag battle for example was headed
to Evo 2018 s line up months before the
game was launched leading to some
controversy
but either through luck or intuition Evo
got it right and cross tag battle is
popular or maybe its presence at Evo
made people take an interest in the game
Eva was built from the ground up by
fighting game fans in a time when
support like this was unheard of now
companies are flocking to Evo because
it's the best way to reach the fgc the
core audience they seem to abandon for
years you may call me G and at this
point it's possible that these companies
need Evo more than evo needs them in
2016
Evo exploded again the launch of Street
Fighter 5 earlier that year brought fans
to Evo in droves with more than 5,000
people in one bracket no other fighting
game tournament has even come close
since not even the next Evo 2017 was
smaller than 2016 but only because
Street Fighter 5s explosion was
unprecedented it was bigger than 2009
bigger than anything and that growth has
also led to other fighting games finding
success so he spent it he met gates
Benson Tekken joined the 1000 club in
2017 and even smaller games like guilty
gear and killer instinct have seen
strong turnouts at Evo 2015 champion oh
my god
Evo itself has even grown to include Evo
Japan a 20-18 tournament that mark Evo's
first time outside North America Evo
2016 was a bigger than ever which meant
the moments were even more explosive
Poway box shocked the world was an
incredible reset and victory over melees
defending champion Armada
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was a very very very Bertie and not
only that at the very very end of the
first set and the second set of grand
finals and Li Jo fought for America and
Street Fighter 5 all the way to top
she's got it is going to know at the end
so takes that he lived in the
roll American representative and while
Evo 2017 may have had smaller attendance
numbers the tournament still saw some
incredible runs JD CR and st. duked it
out for Tekken sevens first-place trophy
salem emerged triumphant over zero after
a grueling 10 game smash 4 grand finals
[Applause]
taquito made one of the greatest top
eight runs of all time ending evo with a
message of love for the fgc that's one
thing I want to say fighting game it's
something so great the next year cojito
made it back to Grand Finals but Street
Fighter crowned an unexpected champion
just before that the Dragonball Fighters
grand finals between sonic Fox and go
Ichi was the most viewed sent in Evo
history wait a minute
know what do not tell me we're going to
sum it are we gonna summon dragon
evolution 2018 champion he's dead he's
done it
[Music]
there is nothing in the world quite like
Evo no eSports tournament in the world
has the history the legacy no tournament
has the sheer number of competitors all
of whom get that same shot at the top no
tournament brings the hype the joy the
sadness and the incredible feeling of
victory that comes with emerging from
hundreds from thousands of competitors
as the champion
but there's more to Evo than just the
winner Evo was built by the fgc and each
year is made not just by the people
behind the scenes working their asses
off it's made by every competitor every
spectator every stream monster who
contributes to the experience Evo is
about the fgc it's a celebration of a
community that's been through everything
it's the greatest tournament in the
gaming world yeah that is the best way
to further email is love the people come
back because this event is unlike
anything else in the entire video game
world yeah and no matter what happens it
only gets better every
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]